the One Piece manga just showed Monkey D
garibus his actual power for the very
first time and it is even more insane
than any of us could have expected and
by that I mean he literally destroys an
entire city with a single gigantic fist
of what does seem to be Advanced
conquerors hockey as he and the Marine
organization swords are about to clash
with Blackbeard's Titanic captains
garp's goal here is of course to rescue
Marine Captain Kobe from the Blackbeard
Pirates and the outcome of this fight
will have massive implications for the
future of the story as we will be
discussing in this video we also learned
the exact remaining devil fruits for the
rest of Blackbeard's Titanic captains
and that for some reason Blackbeard
wants his pirate island to be officially
recognized as a kingdom by the world
government which makes me wonder if he
has an even more crazy plot in mind than
all of his actions leading up to Marine
Forts and on top of that we learned the
true secrets of swords that we have been
dying to know since we first learned
about this insane group of the Marines
by Gamers before we get into the meat
and potatoes of all this craziness I
have to acknowledge today's sponsor
honkai impact third an absolutely
fantastic game from the guys over at
hoyovers that you probably know for
their other fantastic titles like engine
impact or the new honkai Star rail now
this is a 3D hack and slash anime style
game that is centered around intense
battles with your team of Valkyries in a
super open world story and while the
first part of the story had a pretty
perfect ending our girl's story isn't
quite done yet because right now a new
chapter begins with nagazorda with a new
character as Susana will become Valkyrie
quicksand with a pretty awesome looking
new battle suit there are also a ton of
new outfits like this fantastic one
called peachy spring for Elisa and most
importantly two new events during the
meow Town Escapade event you go to this
picturesque looking Valkyrie Resort
Village which is full of adorable
looking little kittens everywhere Gojo
approves and during the whole world Tour
Championship you control chibi
valkyrie's battling against each other
so go and download honkai impact third
right now and use the code new chap to
get 30 crystals
288 asteroids and one character trial
card for free with even more bonus items
for new players now back to the video
starting off with Blackbeard and his
crew Man chapter 1079 shanks's crew
confirmed that Blackbeard was not on
Pirate Island and that turned out to be
exactly the case while we do see several
of his Titanic captains on pirate
Islands Blackbeard himself is absent so
if he isn't here right now there are a
few remaining possibilities for his
current location first of all he could
still be fighting law as we saw back in
chapter 1063 now the exact timelines
here are kind of unclear it is certainly
possible that black could still be
in the massive Clash against the heart
Pirates though seeing how easily Shang
single-handedly destroyed kit and his
crew La will need a minor miracle to get
out of this situation alive on the other
hand this option does make some sense
because none of the Titanic captains
that we see in this chapter were with
Blackbeard during this fight with law
however the other and even more
frightening option is that Blackbeard
could be on his way to eckhit Island as
we have discussed in full detail in the
last chapter review and if this is true
GARP could chase after him once he's
finished here on Pirate Island and this
could start the most epic war since
Marine Ford as we'll discuss in just a
second but first during this chapter we
also get a mind-blowing flashback to
when Blackbeard first had kidnapped Kobe
and in the scene we learned that
Blackbeard apparently wants to use Kobe
as a bargaining chip against the
government what for you ask well in an
insane insane reveal in my opinion we're
being told that Blackbeard wants pirate
Islands to become an official Kingdom as
part of the world government like what
so Blackbeard doesn't want to take down
the world government instead he wants to
join them okay so I mean on the surface
this is such a strange desire for
blackbeards in one piece we've seen
Pirates claiming territory from other
Pirates like when Luffy declared Fishman
Island under his control or Blackbeard's
taking over large parts of whitebeard's
former territory I mean we've even seen
citizens rebelling against the world
government but we've never seen a pirate
wanting to officially join the world's
government as a kingdom really the
closest that we've ever seen to this is
when a pirate becomes a warlord of the
Sea and the world government basically
lets them do whatever they want on that
island for example the warlord's
crocodile and doflamingo that
essentially took over their very own
Islands without anyone interfering but
why does blackbeards care about joining
them especially after he already
betrayed them once well if we look back
at the last time the Blackbeard was
allied with the world government we can
get some idea of what he might be after
here before the time skip Blackbeard
joined the Warlords with the specific
goal of sneaking into imple down and
then recruiting the strongest prisoners
there to his crew now he was obviously
successful with this and that even led
him to stealing whitebeard's legendary
devil fruit after the war when you
really think about it the entire War
this entire crazy sequence of events
never occurs in the first place if
Blackbeard hadn't wanted to join the
Warlords and so if Blackbeard wants to
join the world government again we have
to believe that he has some sort of
ulterior motive that he can only
accomplish as part of the world's
governments what that goal is
it could be the same goal as he had
since the time skip Gathering the
ultimate devil fruits and this theory in
particular gets even more mind-blowing
when we think about what Blackbeard's
inspiration rocks these back won it
during the Battle of God Valley now you
will know that rocks was a pirate 40
years ago who almost conquered the world
with his ridiculously overpowered crew
and there is a strong evidence that
rocks was after the world Noble's devil
fruits when he famously attacked the
island God Valley now after the battle
and Roxas death the island was wiped
completely off the map so we have to
assume that he did not get what he
wanted at that point but what if Roxas
Target on God Valley was then moved to
marijua and Blackbeard knows about this
so he wants to join the world's
government to once again gain access and
steal the world government's most sacred
treasure How likely is that now even
though we learned in this chapter that
the world's government probably won't
trade anything to get Kobe back it is
still crazy to think that Blackbeard is
even attempting to join him once again
but moving on another insane reveal from
this chapter is that the former Marine
Admiral kuzan who now works under
Blackbeard has knowledge about the
secret Marine organization sort now you
might remember that we first learned
about this secret group in chapter 956
when Kobe and the undercover Marine
pirate x-trake are sharing information
during wano we then later meet more of
the members in chapter 1061 and we are
being told in this chapter that swords
members are actually Marines who have
officially resigned so that they're not
technically Marines anymore which at
first sounds bad but it also means that
they can attack and act without the
active approval of the world's
government or the gurosei but the
Marines also won't take responsibility
for their individual actions so they
they can obviously stay secrets and
while we don't know the actual true
objective of this group since kuza knows
about them does this mean that all the
Admirals are aware of this secret
underground organization within the
Marines or did he alone used to be a
member of Sword as well and the most
exciting possibility is of course that
he is still a member of Sword right now
I mean we've always wondered why kuzan
would go from being a marine Admiral to
working with the single most evil
pirates in the world and so it would
only make sense if he was actually an
undercover agent of Sword all along and
we already know that this is possible
because x-strike not only became a
member of the worst generation but also
one of the higher ups in kaido's crew
even though he was a marine all along
though now I guess we know that he was
actually resigned at this point
officially and if koozan should turn out
to be an active member of sort I cannot
wait to learn what he might do in the
future if he's coming to Egghead will he
side with the Blackbeard Pirates or will
he betray Blackbeard to help the world
government or maybe even Luffy or if he
should actually turn out to be on Pirate
Island right now could he help GARP to
rescue Kobe and take down some of
Blackbeard's Titanic captains himself
and yeah we're gonna discuss this a
little bit more in just a second but
speaking of those Titanic captains it
seems that the Blackbeard Pirates truly
have collected some ridiculously
overpowered devil fruits and in this
chapter we finally learned the new and
remaining powers of the rest of the
Titanic captains first we have Alvaro
Pizarro who has the so-called Island
fruit which apparently lets him fuse
with the island and control it similar
to uh this guy who could merge with
stone but I do wonder if this power is
specific to Pirate Island or if it would
work on any Island that he's on and if
it is any Island that is truly a
ridiculously powerful devil fruit in a
world almost completely made up of
either water or Islands also it does
make me wonder like when does something
stop being an island when does it become
land or a consonant like I mean
Australia is technically an island so be
interesting to know how that works
another of the Titanic captains Vasco
shot ate the liquor fruit which is not
only kind of unsurprising but it also
seems to let him manipulate liquor now
in this chapter he creates a liquor
bubble and uses it to fly but I wonder
what other alcohol-based powers this
could possibly give him for example
could he poison people or get them drunk
by attacking them with his liquor or can
he light his Liquor on fire I mean I
feel like Zorro might really approve of
that fruit and we also get confirmation
of San Juan Wolf's devil fruit finally
and while we've already seen him grow
big enough to walk on seafloor he is
confirmed now to have eaten the enlarged
and large fruit which allows him to
change his body size at will and while
we still don't know the exact powers of
this guy's devil fruit we now do know
all of the powers for Blackbeard's
Titanic captains which makes this a
perfect time to start thinking a little
bit about the match-ups between the
straw hats and the Blackbeard Pirates
when they eventually will have their
epic Clash now some matchups are already
pretty much set like Luffy vs Blackbeard
usop vs vanagar but other matchups like
who will Sanji fight are definitely more
interesting to think about and based on
this I'm actually gonna make a full
prediction video on this upcoming fight
so make sure to subscribe if you don't
want to miss out on that one but now
let's get to the most interesting part
of this entire chapter and when I say
interesting I really mean mind-blowing
now in a recent what if video I made
about Luffy possibly being captured by
the Marines GARP actually didn't do too
well against the Blackbeard Pirates but
in this chapter he is an overpowered
monster on a mission to rescue his very
favorite students we already knew that
Garb mostly fights with his massive
punches and overwhelming hockey and upon
his arrival he delivers a supremely
massive punch which destroys the entire
town below the giant skull what and the
display of raw destructive power here is
one of the most insane attacks and
panels that we've seen in the entire
story rivaling kaido and big mom's
combined attack during wano I mean just
look at this beautiful panel he
literally drops a bomb with his fist not
only that we also see streaks of
lightning coming from this attack which
is usually the result of conquerors
hockey so it does seem to suggest that
GARP just like his grandson Luffy has
the advanced Conker's hockey Powers
which does make complete sense since he
was known as the Rival of the former
pirate king Goldie Roger and the former
strongest man in the world's Whitebeard
and while we've been told throughout the
story that Garb was basically their
equal for a good reason many people have
been a little bit doubtful because we've
basically never really seen Garb display
any top tier fighting Power so it was
always a little bit hard to believe that
he was at actually as strong as these
two absolutely legendary figures but
damn does this seem true now I think it
is safe to say that even in his Advanced
age GARP has to be one of the strongest
characters alive in the story right now
and if you remember back during Marine
for it GARP wanted to kill the Admiral
Akainu after he killed Ace now we never
really knew if GARP could actually kill
a kaino or if he even had a realistic
chance of injuring him but looking at
this one panel at the end of the chapter
proves to me that Akino is kind of lucky
that guard was held down by sengoku
during that day and beside garp's power
there are two super important things
that I'm desperate to know based on the
outcome of this battle first Ichiro Ora
the author of One Piece has been
increasing the importance of haki ever
since the time Skip and this was
emphasized even more during the climax
of wano when kairo told us that devil
food powers are alone are not enough to
conquer the Seas and that haki is the
only thing that can truly overcome the
greatest hurdles now this was even shown
to us in chapter 1079 when Shanks who
has no devil fruit but absurdly strong
hockey absolutely devastated kids and
his entire crew who mostly fully relies
on his devil fruit Powers but that now
leads us to this incredibly interesting
battle between GARP and Blackbeard's
Crew That's because Blackbeard's crew
heavily relies on their devil fruit
Powers so so what will happen when a top
of the tier hockey user like GARP comes
up against all of those devil fruit
users at the same time will Oda make a
statement and have GARP come out on top
here showing that no matter what the
strongest hockey wins or can even a top
tier hockey user be overwhelmed by truly
overpowered devil fruits I am dying to
know the answer to this question because
it will have major effects on the entire
story and the eventual clashes with the
straw hats blackbeards and even shanks's
crew and the second most important thing
that I need to know from this battle on
Pirate Island here is how will the
outcome of this fight affect the
immediate close future of the story
right now because obviously the worst
outcome for Luffy but possibly the most
exciting for fans is that GARP is killed
or captured during this battle even
though we see his massive ridiculous
power we never truly know how fights
like this could possibly go or what sort
of trickery Blackbeard's crew might end
up using here and losing his grandfather
would surely make Luffy Rampage just
like when Ace died now personally I
cannot imagine that Luffy would let this
go unavenged so he might go straight for
Blackbeard even if Blackbeard isn't
already coming to Egghead islands and
what would the Marines possibly try to
avenge GARP or would they simply let his
death go however an even more incredibly
exciting option is if GARP is captured
alive this would lead to a similar
situation where Luffy will still try to
save him and another possibility is that
kuzan actually still a sword agent could
free Garb just like when he let Robin go
when she was a child but again the real
question is what would the Marines do
because while GARP is the hero of the
Marines he also openly hates the
celestial dragons and has never taken
any orders from them so they might see
this as a chance to be rid of Garb and
order the Marines not to come and save
him and that could have huge unexpected
consequences for the world Nobles
because the Marines themselves are not
such a bad organization through and
through in general they do try to keep
the peace and protect innocent people
but it is mostly the world Nobles that
are total scumbags and do the worst
things to the people of the world so
what if refusing to come save GARP
causes the Marines themselves to rebel
against the world Nobles and while
garb's death or capture could definitely
change the world we also have to
consider the very likely option of Garb
completely devastating Blackbeard's
Pirates or simply rescuing Kobe and then
leaving remember that garb's main goal
is to bring Kobe back safely so if they
somehow manage to save Kobe and just
Escape then guard would probably
consider that a victory because of the
statement that he gives about Toby
before his massive punch that's because
GARP tells us that Kobe is his beloved
apprentice and that he believes that
Kobe is the future of the Marines and
that's coincidentally perfectly aligns
with Kobe's own goal of one day becoming
a Marine Admiral so we do have to wonder
how far would Garb go to make sure that
Kobe escapes and continues to pursue his
own dream would he sacrifice himself if
necessary I'm getting strong white beard
wipes from this setup right here so
honestly starting to sweat a little bit
that guard might sacrifice himself to
save his favorite pupil here but
whichever of those insane option turn
out to be true if Kobe's able to get
away he could reveal many of
Blackbeard's darkest secrets and that is
because Kobe has been captured for a
couple of weeks now so he could have
learned some of these crazy secrets with
his overpowered observation hockey or
just by being around Blackbeard and
Pirate Island itself and on top of that
in this chapter we see that Kobe has
actually already escaped and is trying
to free the former warlord gekkomoria
from deep within the island so what if
while running around the island Kobe
does find some secret information about
Blackbeard maybe a log Journal some
secret plans or even a trying to rocks
this back and can you imagine if the
world's government were to find out
about Blackbeard's true motivations or
the secrets of how he can eat multiple
devil fruits what if the government
started creating double fruit users with
multiple Powers also if Kobe does
actually manage to free Moria and they
all Escape Pirate Island this will
reintroduce one of the most insane devil
fruit powers back into the story as well
in case you forgot Moria ate the shadow
fruit allowing him to take people's
shadows and create zombies from corpses
now personally I've always thought that
these Powers could be used to revive
some of the most powerful pirates in one
piece for example what if Moria got a
hold of whitebeard's body or Rogers and
there is even this Frozen walls back in
Maurizio that could contain the bodies
of other ridiculously strong fighters
from the past including Joy boy from the
void century and so if Moria had access
to any of these bodies he could create a
super strong Army to clash with the
other incredibly powerful Pirates during
the final war which does make this right
now the most exciting time to be a
one-piece fan because after so many
years we finally get to see the most
insanely strong Fighters actually coming
together for the final race to find the
one piece and the strongest fighter of
them all is undoubtedly red hair Shanks
and if you want to know why that is very
true well you can watch that video right
here Shanks for watching